So we have begun by talking
about general equilibrium.
And uh,
this was the background to the
course so that you're all familiar.
Those of you who haven't taken freshman
economics or intermediate economics,
what's the background that's
required for the course and the,
the fact that general equilibrium
is a part of finances. As I say,
a bit of an innovation because most
finance courses are taught entirely
independently of economic theory.
But the two greatest Yale economist and
two greatest Yale financial economists
have had financing economics integrated.
And I believe that's the only right
way of looking at the problem.
And as I said at the very beginning,
I think the events of the last few
years have confirmed that view.
So let's take up the question today of
why is the free market supposedly so
good?
So we worked out two examples last time.
The first example was,
and the two examples are very similar to
the first problem set that you did. Uh,
in the first example, you've
got two agents, a and B.
And whenever we write agency and B,
we really mean a million agents,
just like a in a million agents.
Just like be the heart of perfect
competition and the economies that there's
lots of people and so we can't,
yeah,
I think it's all right from now, from
now on. And I'm going to be in the glass.
So from,
so the,
so we meet a million people of type
A and a million people have type B.
So the utility function of a,
the welfare function of age written
there and the welfare function of bees
written and each begin with endowments.
Uh,
so when these 2 million
people come together,
they're going to be doing the same
thing that you saw in the class.
And the first day they're
going to be trying.
There can be haggling and arguing and the,
the buyers are gonna always say,
the stuff's not worth very much
and why should they pay so much?
And the sellers are going to say it's
worth a tremendous amount and they should
pay even more. And eventually
they're going to come to prices.
And we discovered last time that the
way of describing what prices and what
final allocations, they come to us by
writing down a system of equations.
And you did that all in your homework.
And we came up with this outcome.
So similarly, we did another problem
in the last class and we wrote down,
uh,
you know,
different welfare functions or utility
functions and different endowments.
And again,
we've got the equilibrium.
So he said that one of the amazing
things is that the system of equations,
the six equations for each economy
that you solved in class always have a
solution. So the, the,
the people who discovered that
discovered it at the Coles Foundation,
they were Ken Arrow.
Um,
Gerard Debreu was a yellow
system professor, Ken Arrow,
who's visiting the cold
foundation in Chicago,
but it was a Stanford professor
and, and, uh, Lionel Mckenzie,
who actually taught at Rochester the
economic equations always have a solution.
So what's so good about that
economic solution, Adam Smith,
about the invisible hand,
but you know,
there was no mathematics in an Adam Smith.
So why do we think equilibrium
is such a good thing after all,
you saw in the example that there were
three pairs of people who for Lauren Lee
couldn't trade it all.
So clearly not everybody gets to trade.
Discrimination happens.
Some people get the stuff,
other people don't get the stuff. Well,
the first approach of economists, uh,
was that equilibrium maximizes
the sum of utilities.
So let's see how that works in,
in this example.
So this example is very special because
everybody thinks that the good why has
constant margin utility of one.
So that's going to play a big role in
our optimization in maximizing the sum of
utilities. So if you want to
maximize the sum of utilities,
you want to maximize the sell. If
utilities, you have to maximize,
um,
a hundred x,
say minus one half x squared plus
30 X v minus one half x v Square,
uh,
squared.
Yeah.
Okay. Uh, plus, let's put
it at the end. Why a plus?
Why B? Hey, such that,
okay,
x plus x B equals 84,
which is the sum of four and 80.
And why a plus?
Why B equals 6,000?
So the claim is that if
all these 2 million people
meeting their meet in a room
like this and start shouting at each
other and trading and offering deals and
stuff, it's going to come down to a final
allocation which we've written over.
There were a gets 77 of the first good
and B get seven of the first good,
and that final allocation is going
to maximize the sum of utilities.
So why should that be the case? In fact,
in this example, it is the case. Well,
why is it the case? Because there's
constant margin utility of y.
So we don't have to worry about
the why allocation at all.
Because if you increase
why AA and decreased,
why be they still have to add up to
6,000 you're going to be lowering A's
utility and raising bees
utility by the same amount.
So you won't have changed
the sum of utilities.
So the whys are totally irrelevant to
this maximizing the sum of utilities.
So all you have to do is make sure that
the x allocation maximize the sum of
utilities for the good acts.
Okay?
So that you can see must
be the case because we can,
we have to maximize the sum
of two people's utilities
are 2 million utilities.
You can always plug in.
X B is a function of x,
a name we 84 so let's write
it as a function of x day.
Okay? And we can replace this
maximization by replay by,
by recognizing that Xb is just
a function of x. Say okay.
In fact, it's a very special
function where the derivative effect
speed with respect to x say
so let's call the function,
we'll call it that to denote that it's
a function happens in equal minus one.
Okay?
So we want to maximize this over x.
Say taking into account that
Xb is just a function of Axa.
Cause if we can't get to maximize,
you have to keep feasible.
So we've now ignored all the constraints.
Constraints have now disappeared.
Provided we keep track of the fact
that Xb is a function of x. Say,
okay,
so why is it the case that the
equilibrium 77 and seven maximizes this?
Well the,
the key is right
finishing margin utility.
We know that the utility function for uh,
here's x utility function for a,
you know,
is quadratic. So it looks
something like that. Okay.
And the utility function for B
also looks something like that.
And so if you look at this function
entirely as a function of a,
it's also going to look like that.
Okay? So by diminishing margin, utility,
mushing,
marginal utility,
the function,
the sum of utilities,
slum of utilities
is concave
cave.
Remember as a picture like that.
So what is the essence
of a picture like that?
It means that setting
derivative equal to zero,
okay?
You can to zero is
equivalent to implies you,
you are at Max.
Okay,
well that's not true of any function.
You know,
if you have a function like that
and then it goes up like that
can have the derivative zero here
and not really be at the Max,
but because there's diminishing
margin utility more and more of x,
there's less and less good.
So it turns down.
So all you have to do is figure
out that the derivative is zero,
which it is at this point.
And then you know you're at the maximum,
but that
at x equals 77 has to be the case because
if you plug in x equals 77 and you
take the derivative of
all this with respect x a,
this whole fang taking into account
as before that XP is a function of x.
Say you just get a hundred minus x say
clause.
Okay,
now it's just going to be 30 minus xb
times the derivative of XP with respect to
x.
Say
why is that? Because you know the
chain rule, if I differentiate,
everything goes back deck.
Say NXP is a function of x,
age 30 cause I'm taking
the door with a to XP,
so it's 30 times the drew of XP
with respect to x. Say, okay,
minus the river was right to XP is XP
times a drove XP with respect to x?
Say
that,
but if you plug in x equals 77 NXB
equals seven DXA DXB Dxa is minus one.
You just get 23 minus 23
equals zero because the margin
utility of a is equal to
the margin utility in be at equilibrium.
The sum of utilities is maximized
and that's the end of the story.
So that you noticed in the problem set
something like that you may not have
given exactly this argument.
That was what you were supposed to have
sort of discovered in doing the problem
set and now we've confirmed what
you already pretty much knew.
So are there any questions about that?
Okay.
It's just the simple generalization of
our football ticket example where the
football tickets end up in the hands of
the people who want the more the most
and a happens to like a lot of tickets,
not just one.
And so a is going to keep buying tickets
until he's bought 77 of them and by
then the next football tickets and let
worth less than 23 two m B she likes
football tickets a little less.
She's not going to buy as many.
By the time she gets down
to a seven football tickets,
she's going to think I'm so,
she hasn't bought in nearly as many when
she's gotten to seven football tickets,
she's going to think the next one's worth
less than 23 and since the price is 23
uh, they're, they're the,
they're going to both stop there.
So they're each going to stop at the
same point with the last ticket is worth
the same to each of them and all
the previous football tickets,
each bod is worth more than each of them.
So there's no way of rearranging
the tickets. Cause if you did,
you'd have to take a football ticket
that was worth more than 23 from one of
them and give a that ticket to the other
one who buy them would think it was
worth less than 23 so that's,
that's the argument.
Okay.
So economists were,
fell were beside themselves
with their brilliance.
And having proved this theorem and given
a mathematical form to the invisible
hand, whenever you take a verbal argument
like Adam Smith and turn it into a
mathematical argument, you've understood
it better. You understand why it's true.
And you also start to understand why in
some circumstances it might not be true.
So for 50 years,
let's say between 30 and 50 years,
this was the fundamental argument of
economics and economic equilibrium that I
could live on was a good thing,
cause it maximize the sum of utilities.
But then little by little,
starting with Irving Fisher and a bunch
of people at the same time and a little
bit later,
so Hixon Samuelson are famous for this.
They began to wonder what kind of
crazy utility functions are these where
there's some mysterious God that
has constant margin utility of one.
So in modern terms, how could you
justify it? You could say, well,
maybe there's a machine where we,
uh,
can calibrate exactly how happy
people are and we can measure it.
So for example, we can measure how
much, uh, how many, how many, uh,
how aroused their skin is.
What would you know the, the,
the skin texture changes as you,
as you become less than more rounds.
Maybe we could measure that. You know,
with Mris we can measure brainwaves.
Maybe you can calibrate
how many brainwaves were
spinning around and how happy
somebody isn't.
Maybe there's some mysterious good like
food that has constant margin utility.
Well that doesn't seem very persuasive
to me. And it wasn't to the economist.
So the beginning of the 20th century,
they all argued starting
with Irving Fischer that it
made no sense to think that
we could actually measure
utility and, and, and,
and more than that made even less sense
that be some good that had constant
margin utility of one.
So Fisher put everything on
a symmetric footing and said,
let's think of the two goods x and
y is more or less symmetric. I mean,
there's no reason why one has
to have some special role.
So let's look at this equilibrium,
which we got the same way.
And you did this on a problem
set solving correct delivering.
Does this maximize the sum of utilities?
Well,
the answer is if it did maximize the sum
of utilities at the final allocation,
we couldn't gain anything by switching,
you know,
reducing nine fifths a little bit and
increasing six fifths a little bit.
But what is the sum of utilities?
Okay,
so if you write WIA plus WV
okay, it's going to be for one
thing, three fourths log x,
say plus.
Um,
two thirds log XP.
So let's look at the margin utility to EC.
Save Good.
A,
that's three fourths.
So margin utility of a x plus margin
utility of B x equals three fourths times
one over nine fifth,
which is five ninth. Okay,
that equals 15 over 36,
which is five over
18.
If I've done that right,
it doesn't sound right. Um,
right.
512 thank you. That
sounds better. And now,
but let's look at the,
so this is the margin
utility of X. Say, okay,
is a five twelves what's
the margin utility, uh,
to be a vax? Well, n equals two thirds
times one over six fast,
which is five,
six a,
which is 10 over 18,
which is five over nine.
So these two numbers are different.
The margin utility to be
is bigger than the margin.
Utility of acts is bigger than
the margin utility. The a of x.
So clearly the final equilibrium
allocation doesn't maximize the sum of
utilities.
By switching some goods from a to B.
You could make both people better off.
So that was a shock to economist.
It meant that the argument they'd relied
on the thing which they were using to
persuade, you know, policy people that a,
the free markets were good thing
was a pho is a false argument.
It rests on a premise that's indefensible,
namely that there's constant margin
utility and everybody can measure it.
So they needed some other definition
of some other way of capturing the
mathematical idea that the
invisible hand is a good thing.
And the reason I'm spending
so much time emphasizing this,
even though you've seen this before, is
because if economist made a mistake once,
what makes you think they
haven't made another mistake?
So now let's give the argument that,
uh,
in a week or since the invisible hand
holds that is that the free market comes
to a very, uh, socially
desirable equilibrium.
And later in the course we're going to
find that their argument is also too
narrow.
So my point that I'm going to gradually
get to is that economists have
constantly taken too narrow and
too special view of the world.
And as you enlarge the view of the world,
you have not by making things
mathematically simpler, actually,
you have to make the mathematically
slightly more complicated.
As you enlarge the view
of the world you have,
you get closer to the truth and you
start to find that the free market isn't
quite as wonderful as you thought
at first. And therefore there's a,
there's room for government regulation.
So it's not as Paul Krugman argued
that that economists are transfixed by
mathematics and seduced into,
into simple conclusions that the free
market is perfect. On the contrary,
I would say they buy,
they were afraid of too much mathematics.
And by looking too narrowly, they didn't
realize what they could have just by,
by being mathematically more
sophisticated. So it's a
failure of sophistication,
not too much sophistication.
So what did,
what did the economists argue so that
the chief among them, Hicks, Anderson,
Paredo and Fisher,
all these people basically came to
the same conclusion. They said, well,
it makes no sense to maximize,
to talk about the sum of utilities.
Let's talk about predo efficiency.
So an allocation. So, so we began,
so what's the general problem?
The general problems you
start with an economy.
Okay. Made up of all these individuals,
let's call them waa and WB,
but it could be as many as we want.
So let's just say Wwi and II.
I,
so he,
I is the endowment of x and I of why.
So that's the economy.
And now every,
so you start from the economy
and you'd go to equilibrium.
An equilibrium is a price factor.
P X,
P Y and allocations x,
Y,
Aye. Aye. Aye. Such that.
Okay.
Summation for all the eyes of x equals
the summation for all the eyes of e X.
Okay. So everyone's fine. Ice
Final consumption of ax plus js,
final consumption of eggs, plus everybody
else's final consumption of eggs.
Those are the son of the exercise is equal
to the summer. Everybody's endowment.
And similarly for the wise,
alright, let's see, I why
and such that everybody is doing
what's in their personal interests,
which is maximizing. W I have x, Y,
z Max of Wwi.
Exci such that he acts a times
x Plus p y times y equals t x,
x plus B.
Why did y eat y is solved
by XII. Why? All right.
That's the definition of equilibrium.
Everybody individually optimizes,
looking at his own budget.
Set the hell with everybody else.
Does the best in his interest chooses
exci why I at the going prices?
Supply equals demand.
That's how you get the final allocation.
So that's the definition of equilibrium
and now we're trying to argue that's a
good thing. Okay, and
so what's our criterion?
Well,
what parade on edge worth and everybody
else decided is let's look at the
welfare functions,
Waa and WB.
So if you take some allocation, like
the original allocation to one and one,
two you'll have a utility, a welfare
of each person. Three fourths log,
two plus one quarter log,
one. That's the welfare bay.
And Welfare will be, will be two
thirds log, one plus one third log too.
So that'll be some point here.
So this is welfare.
Be Welfare,
a at initial endowment.
Okay?
Neutral endowment.
And if you look at the welfare at the
final allocation, so three quarters,
LogMeIn, fiscals, one portal
log, three halves, you know,
it's going to be something like this,
it's gotta be up here.
So it's going to be better for
both people. How do you know that?
Because a had the choice of just
buying his initial one down,
one that's always affordable,
and he chose not to do it.
He chose to do something else and he
was better off in the same with B.
So clearly the equilibrium allocation
is going to be better than the initial
endowment. And so the parade
or criterion Pareto criterion
is that, um, uh,
an allocation
x hat I y hat I paredo dominates
allocation.
So this is for all I
XII.
Let's put the eyes on the top.
Yes.
If and only f everybody's better off.
That'd be you.
I excellent.
I had,
it's bigger than w x, Y, y.
So
we started with an allocation,
the allocation here,
and then we moved to
competitive equilibrium here
and everybody may was better
off.
So the [inaudible] allocation prayed
or dominates the initial allocation.
But now the question is maybe there's
some other allocation besides the
competitive, I could live my
allocation that dominates, um,
that dominates the equilibrium allocation.
So this
CRM CRM is that
if p x, y,
y I,
I and I is an,
uh, is a, an equilibrium
for the economy. The economy. He
remember we defined the economy.
He put he here.
Yeah.
Van,
no allocation.
X Hat on I y hat. All right. I am,
I pereno dominates.
All right.
So why
if
summation XII hat equals
I x
and summation,
it's got a little too tight here.
Sorry about this. Y Hat. I equals.
This is overall y equals summation.
E I why?
Okay. So let's, let's,
yeah, I can read this,
this really bad critical
line right in the corner.
So I'll just say it in words and
then read it literally. So this,
this allocation dominates this one.
The competitive equilibrium
dominated the initial endowment.
But maybe there's some other way of
rearranging the gods that gets you even
further out here. So what I'm, the
Theorem says that's impossible.
So it says if you start with a competitive
equilibrium with an allocation xy,
y for the economy,
he the no allocation like that one.
No allocation x I had,
why I had can pray will dominate it.
This couldn't happen. You'd have to be
down here somewhere. That couldn't happen.
Provided this other
allocation used up there
resources that were available. So the
sum of the xs and this allocation is the,
some of the initial endowments
and the sum of the YS.
And this allocation is the some of the
initial endowments over the people.
So nothing else. Of course, if
you add more goods to the economy,
you can make everybody better off. But
using the existing goods in the economy,
which is the sum of the aix
is in the son of the Ui wise,
there's no way to make everyone better
off than at the competitive equilibrium.
So it says literally if p EXCI why is an
equilibrium for the economy e which is
that which includes the initial
endowments, the no allocation Exci hat.
Why I hat parade? Oh dominates EXCI. Why?
If the sum over, I have x
hat, eagles are some over,
I have e I x,
and if the sum of the y eyes
over I equals y had eyes over,
I equals the sum of the EIY.
Okay, and others, that's the theorem.
So we've totally weakened the
definition of equilibrium.
So might be that if you, if you add,
if this is the competitive allocation,
if you look at this line,
this is same psalm of utilities,
right?
Because of the slope is minus one.
And here's the utility to
be in the utility to a,
everything on this line
has the same utility.
So that theorem would say anything else
that's feasible had to be down here.
The sum is less than that.
But here we're not saying that we're
no longer saying that maybe you can
increase the sum from this sacral
liberty and you could increase the sum by
taking something away from a and giving
it to be, you could increase the sum.
Okay,
so that would have been here.
You increase the sum so you no longer
maximize the sum. But the fact
is to make, be better off.
He had to make a worse off. And that's
the new criteria. Predo efficiency.
Okay.
So that's the CRM and now we're going to
prove it so that you can see the whole
logic of the free market
is just amounts to that.
So there are any questions about this?
Do you all supposedly saw this before?
But um, that doesn't mean you really
did. So does anyone have a question?
What's going on? It's a very
basic, incredibly important idea.
Okay.
All right.
So have you one more chance.
Somebody must have a question.
Yes.
Can.
Yes. Why don't I draw a picture, which
is what I was going to do anyway.
So let's draw a picture
and I'll,
I'll bring the theorem back
after having drawn the picture.
Okay. So the picture is
going to be due to Edgeworth.
So he invented the indifference curve
and invented it in order to draw this
picture. That was incredibly
clever picture. So he says,
let's look at this economy. And the
one on the right that we start with,
we put x a here,
an Xb here,
and you notice that a begins
with an endowment of two.
One.
So let's put as endowment to one here.
Okay,
so this is he a x equal to,
and this is e B e a y equal one.
Right. That makes sense. Okay. Now we can
draw indifference curves through that.
So there's difference curves. He
likes x more than he likes. Why?
So the difference curves are going
to be sort of vertical right up.
He doesn't like to give up x very much.
So he's in different curves are
going to look sort of like this.
Okay.
And the most important indifference curves
are the ones where he gets better off
than he was before. So now in the
end, they're going to be some price.
He's going to have a,
there's going to be a budget set,
which is x is way more expensive than y.
So there's going to be a budget
set that looked like this.
That's sort of the budget
set that he faces. Right?
And he's not going to choose this.
It turns out he chooses
something like here, which is, um,
he chooses a little bit
less of acts nine fifths.
Yeah.
Okay. And a little bit
more of why. So here's x,
say equals nine fifth which is a little
less than two and xb he chose was a,
I can't read it, three halves,
which is more than one. Okay.
Are you with me? That make, are
you, you asked the question,
does this picture make sense?
Okay, so he obviously did better
than he did before, but
it's really, you know,
we've got another guy to worry about.
So how can you put the second
guy in the same diagram? Well,
let's just finish.
Let's just add the total endowment.
Where's the total endowment?
Well, it's three units of
each. So here we've got two.
So this is one.
MMM.
To this must be three.
Okay,
so total endowment of good x is three
two plus one is three and I'm good.
Why is three as well?
Here's one, here's two.
Here's three was supposed to be a square.
So heres the aggregate endowment.
It's here.
This is the total endowment.
Three of three of each. Okay.
But now we can do,
we can put B.
All right.
So what is feasible?
What are the feasible allocations?
So this is a,
an extremely clever inside
of edge worth. He said, look,
the total endowment is three common three.
If I tell you that a has got two
common one, that's this point,
what's leftover be must be consuming.
So bees consuming the
distance from here to here,
which is obviously one comma two and if
a ends up over here at nine 53 halves,
okay? That's from here to here is nine
fifths and three halves since the total is
three three B's obviously doing,
consuming what's leftover.
So he's consuming this difference.
Okay? So whatever a does,
you can see in the diagram
looking at it the normal way.
But if you just sort of twist your
mind a little bit and look from this
direction, once you know what a is doing,
you can figure out what bees doing.
So each of these points
defines a feasible allocation.
Okay? And now what we want
to say, the Theorem says,
look at the utilities that a and
B I got out of this allocation.
A God is on this indifference curve.
You know what he's doing cause it be,
you know it was coming from here.
We know how he's, how he's doing.
So look at the allocation they got.
You can't make both people better off
than that by choosing some other point in
this square. So let's look at
it from bees point of view.
From bees point of view, he likes
more of everything. So if a gets less,
B's going to get more. So from bees
point of view, the further out you go,
this way the veteran is
for for a, B, c, so B's,
the axes for B looks like that.
So he's going to have
some indifference curve.
That
B's indifference curve is going to look.
MMM,
he's indifference curve
has to look like this.
So here's where be started here.
And then B's going to be
better off doing lists.
So B's indifference curve looks,
something like that.
Those are Bs and difference curves.
Okay. So the further out you go
this way, the better off P is.
So as you shrink with aid gets,
that obviously means bees getting more.
And so bees getting happier
and happier. Okay. So what,
what is the definition of prey to
efficiency? Whatever point we pick.
Like this one to begin with. Is there
a way of making both people better off?
Well, the answer is the competitive
equilibrium makes both people better off.
Why is that? If you can
see it from back there. Uh,
the reason is that a went from this
white indifference curve to a better
indifference curve over here be who's
budget line is the same budget line looked
at from his point of view.
He went from his indifference
curve over here to one here.
Okay. So he went from this yellow
indifference curve to a better one.
So both of them got better off going
to this, uh, final allocations.
And they started with,
and of course that had to be true because
a could always have chosen to stay
where he was at two one he moved to nine.
Fifth three has cause it was
better and B could have started,
stayed where she was at one. Two she
chose to go to five. Two to six fifths.
Three has cause it made her better off.
So both of the must be better off at the
final allocation and the word to begin
with. Okay. Now what is the
theorem say? The theorem says,
remember in pictures it says whatever
point we pick here that defines something
for a and define something for B.
Then we can look at the utility
welfare functions of both and see what
indifference curves there
on the theorem says.
There's no other point
in this whole diagram,
which puts both a and B on a higher
indifference curve for each of them than
they were at the competitive equilibrium.
So if I read the definition again,
it says if I'm at,
if I start with an economy there with
the endowments and the Utility Functions,
so the endowments and the indifference
curves and I compute the competitive
equilibrium like we did over
there. Okay, then no allocation,
that means no point in that box could
make everybody better off than they were
at the competitive equilibrium provided
that Newpoint is in the box.
So it makes the sum of the xs equal to
the sum of the endowments and the sum of
the ys equal to the sum
of the endowments of why.
Okay.
So Edgeworth this is the end of the proof.
We already gave the proof according to
Edgeworth. Okay, so what's the proof?
According to Edgeworth, he says it's all
a matter of looking at it the right way.
It's easy to look at the
picture from aes point of view.
You just look at the x
axis and the y axis. Okay?
This is the y axis.
What is this?
This is,
this is a x. A why it
was three halves. Okay,
so you look at it. So this is the y
axis going this way. This is the y axis.
And this is the x axis
going this way for a,
it's very simple to look at the y
axis and the x axis for a A's got his
indifference curve getting
better and better. Okay. And um,
B. Okay, so from [inaudible]
point of view, it's very simple.
You look at the endowment,
you draw the budget line through it,
which is some linear line,
and then a picks.
The best point in that budget
set drawing the tangent,
which is the white indifference
curve to this point right here.
That's the best he can do.
Now the trick is to see that
from bees point of view up here.
From these point of view of here,
things look very similar because bees
and downwind is also at this point he's
got one unit up here of
x and two units of y.
Okay, why does he have that? Because
the two together added up to three.
So if this is what A's and dumb it was,
then of course what's leftover is bs
endowment, so be it has to go here.
Now what is the budget set
look like for me? Well,
it's also a linear thing with the same
slope and it goes through this point.
So from his point of view,
this pink line is also his budget set.
It goes from here all the way down to
where it hits his y axis down here they've
got the same budget set. Just looked
at it from opposite sides. Okay.
And now what does competitive equilibrium
and supply equals demand means it
means that we're an AA chooses
this point as the best point. Okay.
Which happened to have been nine fifths,
three halves then be is happy to choose
what's leftover is his best point.
So his optimal point on
his indifference curves,
that's tangent to his budget set has
to be the same point looked at from his
origin instead of A's origin. That's
the trick. And so now you real, okay.
So that's the key insight that
Edgeworth had, his beautiful picture.
And now the point is that if the quite
indifference curve looks like that,
anything that makes a better off
has to be on this side of the white
indifference curve.
And the yellow indifference curve,
which is B's indifference curve,
anything that makes her better off has
to be on this side of the yellow curve.
But the white curve goes that way
and the yellow curve goes that way.
So there's no point that's simultaneously
above A's indifference curve and also
above B's indifference curve. So therefore
nothing could parade or dominate it.
So that's the Edgeworth proof.
Yes.
Right?
That the pink budget line describes
what you can afford to buy,
describes the budget equation,
this equation.
So everyone's going to
choose on the pink line.
Okay? Now what's feasible as they could
choose, any points, it's feasible.
You're going to cook this point is
feasible. B gets almost nothing in a,
it gets almost everything.
Bees never going to let himself be forced
down there because B can choose on the
pink wines.
He's always going to choose
something better than that.
Yeah.
Okay, so that's proof number one. I'm just
going to give proof number two. So okay,
you've,
most of you've seen this before,
but I'm going to give another proof
and then I'm going to ask you a quick,
then I'm going to see whether you really
understand what all this means. Okay?
So here's a second proof.
Okay? And this is a much
better proof. So now approve.
So I'm gonna write this Algebraic late,
the proof of Arrow 1951
and Dobro 1951 separately.
Okay, so this is called the fundamental
theorem of economics first welfare theme,
or if economics. Okay.
So all this picture,
I'll stuff make so many
assumptions. You'll, there
are only two kinds of traders.
They're only two goods.
There's somehow never,
because they're consuming only
on the boundaries. I mean,
they're never consuming on the boundaries.
It's always in this on know it,
just so many special assumptions and,
and uh,
everything's two by two
and it's just special case.
So let's give a much more
general proof of this theorem.
So here we've got two
goods won't play any role.
There could be any number of goods.
There are two goods only here,
but there are many traders,
lots and lots of traders.
So what's the proof that x hat,
why hat couldn't parade?
Oh dominated.
So suppose that we've got
this is equal to summation,
x hat I,
and this is equal to the summation.
Okay,
why Hat I? Okay, so we've
got another allocation,
which is feasible.
Cool.
So could it be that this other feasible
allocations of x hats and white hats,
could that make everybody better off?
Could that make each I
better off than Exci? Why I,
and this proof is so short
and so beautiful, so elegant.
And so convincing that it's mesmerize
people now for over 50 years and it,
it prevents them from seeing that
there could be even a more in general
situations where things aren't so great.
So what is the proof? It's two lines.
If x at y hat is really better for I
then I claim line one w I have x hat,
uh, y hat. I, okay, this is, sorry.
So this is this line zero.
This is just repeating what's the case?
Wwi of x had high.
Why had I greater than W EXCI why?
Hey, that's for all I, that's
the claim. Could this happen
that you've got a feasible x hat?
I why had I and it makes everybody
better off than Exci. Okay.
Could this happen? The answer is
no. Line one is, if that were true,
then it would have to be the case that p
x times x Xy hat plus p y times y hat I
had to be greater than p x
times x Plus p y times e I.
Why?
Why is that?
Because the budget set of Mr I says
he spends all his money on x and Y in
his budget set and does the best he can.
Okay, this is Saul's Exci
why I solves this problem.
So if this thing really makes them
better off than what he chose,
it can't be that it was
affordable. Otherwise he would
have bought this instead.
I ain't bought this instead.
So it has to be that this Alec can for I,
this bundle costs more than he can afford.
That's why
choose it.
So this relies
on agent rationality.
Everybody given his choices, he doesn't
care about the rest of the world,
but given his choices,
everybody's doing the best thing he can.
Okay. Now, Shiller would say people
make mistakes. They're crazy.
They have no idea what they're
doing. They're stupid. They're,
there's some guy tells him a story
and the bar one night and they totally
changed their life around. They switched,
you know, the, so he'd say, well,
this isn't true. All right. But anyway, I,
I actually believe that people have
more sense about deciding for themselves
what's good for them. Then third parties
do about deciding what's good for them.
So I don't want to challenge
this.
So if you don't challenge this,
you conclude that if something
makes everybody better off,
each person must have found
this allocation unaffordable.
Otherwise he would have chosen it
over pie ea.
I why it's all I did was that's
true for every single person I saw.
I could add this inequality for I plus
listen to quality for j plus this and
equality for all the people.
And then I use the distributive law to
take the sum inside and I have this,
okay,
but that is impossible and that's the
end of the proof because the sum of this
XII x had I is equal to this son.
That was what we are supposed.
You're just rearranging all the goods
that are really there and this, um,
is the same as this.
Um,
so therefore since the new allocation
just rearranges the endowment differently
from the equilibrium and rearranges
the x's maybe differently from the
equilibrium,
it has to be that actually this thing on
the left is equal to this thing in the
right. It's identical to it. So I can't
be greater. And that's the contradiction.
That's the end of the proof.
So it's two lines,
two lines to prove what you know.
Adam Smith's spent 400 pages arguing
that the free market is a good thing.
Okay. So this is the basis for the
idea that we shouldn't regulate,
we shouldn't regulate, we
shouldn't. Sounds pretty convincing.
So any questions about this?
Anything that you'd like to say? I'm,
are you convinced by this?
Okay. So what are some reasons you don't
believe this? I need some obvious reason.
Yes. Well, even if this would make sense,
a lot of regulation policies changing
the pricing of the things anyways,
so we're not necessarily,
no, but that's so you.
Okay. So it's a good,
so that glad you asked that
question cause it no, no,
it betrays a misunderstanding.
So I'm glad you asked that question.
So suppose that someone came in a given
these assumptions that we've made.
Okay. So this theme is correct, given
the assumptions. Now he made a standard.
Okay. So there was a little bit
mistake in the reasoning he made.
I'm going to repeat his question,
change it a little bit so maybe he'll
deny this is what he was saying.
But I believe what he just said is what
really happens in a lot of regulations
as they come in and they change
the prices, they tax and good,
they prevent people from trading so much.
So the price changes,
they subsidize something, something
happens so that you get different prices.
And of course if those different
prices you get a different allocation.
And then he said that's all true so far.
And then he said,
because there are different prices,
um, you know, you can't compare the,
the original equilibrium allocation
to the new aqua lived from allocation.
Well that's where he
short changed this proof.
This proof says,
however you get to a new allocation x hat.
I why had I,
maybe it's because the government has
intervened and changed all the prices and
done a bunch of other stuff, but in
the end, after all that intervention,
the government is going to get you to
a new allocation x had I why had I and
that new allocation can't be better
than the original one. Okay. So,
so that's the force of the argument.
No matter what the government does,
it's going to, in the end, the, the upshot
is a new allocation EC Sadye why had I,
we don't have to think about how
it got there. That's where it got,
and according to this argument,
it can't be better.
So the argument is correct and elegant.
There must be something
missing to the arguments.
Some assumption you don't really
believe, if you doubt the argument, yes,
your allocation,
even at the expensive,
what if you want an allocation?
It's socially desirable that
have an allocation that's
better for one party even
if that comes up.
Another one.
Okay, so one argument you could
say is that all right, it may be.
And the Aqua Librium that a,
okay. So who's better off here?
You notice that this equilibrium a ends
up with more of everything than B does.
Okay,
so a,
so you could say the second is not very
socially desirable because a ends up
with more of everything than
B does released as much of
everything is speed does
and that unjust and unfair.
And so we don't like the allocation.
And so maybe we should
move something from a to B.
So that's an argument on the basis
of justice. It says we can find,
just are allocations, uh, that are
somehow socially more desirable.
But this argument of Predo
efficiencies about efficiency, okay,
maybe you could, uh, you know, you,
you could hurt a to help B because
that's, you know, serves your,
your desire for fairness.
But that doesn't say anything about
how efficient the allocation is.
It's still true that the original
allocation was efficient in the sense you
couldn't make anyone better off.
So the economist would say,
in order to hurt a and help be,
what you should do is take some of A's
and downwind away from him and give it to
her and then let them trade to a new
competitive equilibrium where she began
with more than him.
So the just thing to do is to rearrange
the resources at the beginning and still
let people trade to a final allocation.
Okay. So that's an argument from fairness,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't interfere.
It doesn't contradict the economic
argument that fair or unfair.
It's still efficient.
We've done as well as we could,
making everyone as happy as we can
and maybe we can hurt someone and help
someone else. We can't help everyone at
the same time. Whereas most regulation,
the argument in favor of regulation is
you're helping everybody by regulating.
And this says you can't ever do that.
So what's missing?
What's some of the assumptions should
be an elementary question for you. Yes,
no,
it's got all those assumptions.
So there's something about the model
that's too narrow and you should be,
and this should be easy and you're going
to tell me obvious things where it's
too narrow and then a and the, so I'm
going to just say where we're going.
You're supposed to be telling me now
obvious ways. This is too narrow.
I'm going to say you're right.
You're right, you're right.
But finance is different. We don't have
to worry about those problems supposedly.
So go ahead. Back there. You. Okay.
So one critical shortcoming of this
argument is that there are externalities.
Suppose that,
um,
ex is cigarettes and a smoking,
buying and smoking more
cigarettes makes be sick. Okay?
So that's not part of this.
Why is that not part of this?
Because bees utility depends only on
bees consuming, not what AI is doing.
Okay.
So there's no place in this model,
it's too narrow to include externalities.
So it doesn't capture the
fact that a might be making,
he by smoking might make her sick by
smoking so many cigarettes and that's not
in here. And if you put the idea
that utility bees, utilities,
her utility might depend on what he's
doing and now with just not what she's
doing, the fear, it won't be true.
So there's a reason to tax pollution and
to tax cigarettes and all those things
because of externalities. Okay. So that's
the fun. That's a fundamental problem.
Yes.
Well, we're assuming diminishing margin
utility, but there are different,
each person has a different curves.
So yes,
we assume that they're all
curved away from the origin.
So we assumed diminishing margin
utility. But I think you know, that,
that I'm almost prepared to believe
diminishing margin. Utill you know,
it's not literally true. You don't like
two tickets are better than, you know, uh,
going from moving from one ticket to two
tickets may be a huge gain in utility
cause now you can bring your friend along
and going to third, a third ticket. Uh,
you know,
going from getting one ticket might not
be worth much because you don't want to
go alone.
Getting the second one may add a huge
amount of utility that's an increasing
margin utility, but eventually
after you've got enough tickets,
it's going to be diminishing margin
utilities. So I believe on the whole,
the diminishing margin. Utilities,
not such a bad assumption,
but this clearly relies on that.
So you're right, but I'm not,
I don't think that's the critical
problem. What else is there? Yes. What?
Okay. Credit markets. Right
now we're starting to talk
a little bit about finance.
So just hold that thought for one second.
Anything else you can think of besides
externalities? That's terrible for,
okay, so, all right, so, okay,
so let me transition this way.
So of course people noticed externalities
and other kinds of regulation is
perfect competition.
And you know,
we assumed everyone took the
prices has given there are enough,
there was no monopolist,
you know,
setting the price and refusing to
bargain with people and stuff like that.
So regulation could come about in order
to enforce the competitive equilibrium
to allow for perfect competition.
So we assumed that already,
that's one place for regulation and
a second place is because of these
externalities. So for a hundred,
you know, 50 to 100 years,
everybody has accepted
those two arguments.
Clearly there's a place for
regulating free markets,
ensuring free markets and stopping
trusts and monopolies and for stopping
externalities.
But then people said
finance okay is different.
As long as you know there aren't
any externalities. You know,
you're just trading stocks and bonds,
there's no pollution.
Nobody's going to get sick because
someone else has a stock or a bond.
Some people,
it might be jealous,
but we're not really going to
take that into account. We don't,
we don't want to honor those
kinds of feelings of jealousy.
So the arguments seem to
be when you get to finance,
you don't have to worry
about externalities. And yes,
you have to worry about
perfect competition.
But once you've got perfect competition,
that's the end of the story.
So the rest of the course now
is going to be, if you've,
if you forget about externalities,
okay,
because you forget about
pollution because you know,
there were trading pieces of paper,
they're not polluting anything.
Why shouldn't the financial
markets be efficient?
Why doesn't this argument
apply to the financial markets?
And one of the critical financial
markets is the credit market.
So can you understand the credit market
on just these terms and therefore argue
that the market's efficient.
So we're going to spend a large part
of the course talking about that.
So unless you had some
particular point to raise,
now I'm going to just use your
comment is a good introduction to the,
to the next part of the course. Okay. So,
so far there's nothing that seems
to directly involve finance,
what we've been talking about.
So where does the finance come in?
So Irving Fisher was the
person who created the first
really general equilibrium
model of finance. So he was
a Yale undergraduate. Uh,
he, you know, was a superstar at Yale
undergraduate and he invented a, anyway,
he had an, he had graduated
first in his class from Yale.
He decided that he was a math major.
He decided that he wanted to go.
He wanted to build an economic,
uh, financial Eq Librium model.
There were no economists
there at his time.
We're talking in the late 18 hundreds.
And so he went to Gibbs,
the famous physicist,
maybe a Ma, you know,
one of America's most famous physicist at
the time and said, can you, can you, uh,
advise an ex, uh, you know, an
economics phd? And Gibbs said, well,
if it's mathematical enough and has a
model and something, yes, I can do it.
And so,
fishers a PhD dissertation was basically
reinventing this general equilibrium
model that I've just described,
and then making a machine to calculate
equilibrium with water and pumps and
water seeking its own level
and solving for equilibrium.
And we had this machine up until
the 1970s in the Coles Foundation.
Well when it got stolen and, uh, some,
some engineer named Srinivasa and about
10 years ago was ready to rebuild the
machine because we have the dissertation
where it explains very carefully how
Fisher built his machine and
he was going to rebuild it.
And then he was offered Elbar
dies job Albara die is the guy,
the nuclear inspector who you know,
goes to a rock and says they're building
nuclear stuff and not building this.
And so he was offered that job and so he
left Yale and then decided not to take
the job after all. So he's still got
Albury die in the job. And, but anyway,
he left Yale and so we never
got the machine built. Uh,
he was a great guy. And, uh,
anyway, so Fisher, uh, after, um,
Fisher after writing this dissertation
stayed at Yales and assistant professor
got tenure.
It became the most famous economist
probably in the country for awhile. Um,
he invented finances.
I'm about to tell you.
And he in in a way, this model of finance
I'm about to present, which was the,
you know,
in retrospect,
clearly the most interesting
model of finance if it's time.
And he was a financial economist,
but he was famous for,
he also was an entrepreneur. So you'll
see later that he started his own company.
It was a pro computer company called
Remington and he managed to make $10
million, uh, for his company
in the early 19 hundreds and a,
he was a friend of Roosevelt's and
he kept advising Roosevelt during the
depression to print more money. He said,
print more money, print more money,
put more money in the Yale Library has
all these letters he sent to Roosevelt.
And it also has Roosevelt's responses
where you can tell that Roosevelt is
paying no attention to them.
But,
but Fisher's ego seemed to be so
big that he just, I mean, you know,
Roosevelt says,
I'm very glad that the good professor has
made such more the recommendations and
we'll certainly take them seriously.
And then Fisher writes back and says,
I'm glad you're going to follow.
What I suggested. And so, so anyway,
Fisher convinced that the
economy was going to turn around,
poured all his money into this
computer company, Remington,
the company and the
great stock market crash,
nearly went bankrupt and was
leveraged. So he had to go to his, uh,
he had to go to his wife who was very
wealthy and borrow her money and that they
lost that money.
Then he went to her parents and borrow
all their money and lost that money.
And finally he'd lost
everything of his own money,
his wife's money and his
wife's parents money.
And they're about to take his house
from him, foreclosed on his house.
And so Yale was forced to buy his house
forums so he can continue to teach.
And so,
so he set a bad precedent for economist
at Yale because whenever any economist
at Yale has financial
advice to give someone,
always quotes Irvin Fischer's 1929
line that the economy had reached a
permanently high plateau. And,
but anyway, despite all that,
he still, uh, his theories
are well worth studying.
He was famous for a few other things.
He's a little bit Shiller as
Cooley trying to imitate Fisher.
Fisher wrote a huge number of books,
50 books about everything.
So he got tuberculosis and he survived
and he wrote a series of books on good
living in good health and how to
combat tuberculosis. So he said,
you had to exercise, you have to get fresh
air. And these were huge bestsellers.
And um,
then he said that drinking
was a terrible thing.
So he did an experiment in class where
he would have his students do pushups,
then he'd give them all of our teeny,
then he'd count how many
pushups they could do,
and then you give them a second Martini
in countering the questions they could
do.
And he found that there was a
10% reduction for each Martini.
And so he said that prohibition,
since the average business
person had two drinks at lunch,
the prohibition would increase output
by 20%. And so he's one of the,
he was one of the leading,
he was one of the leading proponents of,
of prohibition. So in that,
after the stock market crash,
he helped form the Coles
Foundation. Um, so he,
so he, and a bunch, so what, so Coles, uh,
who was a Yale undergraduate,
uh, had run a very famous,
uh, uh, macro forecasting
company in the 1920s.
And in 1929, the stock market crashed and
he, there were a whole series of these,
they said newsletters, you know,
same kind of stuff they do now. He,
unlike all the others,
after the fact realized that he hadn't
anticipated anything about the crash,
much like nobody anticipated it now.
And he was so embarrassed.
He went and collected not only his
old recommendations themselves,
but all his competitors.
And so he published a famous paper
in which he argued that it, you know,
economist had no idea what
they were talking about,
the fact that they were frauds.
And so he went to his old economist,
Irving Fisher at Yale and said,
look,
I just believe that economics
without mathematics has no meaning.
I want to start a mathematical
wing of economics.
And I've got a lot of
money. He, his, his, uh,
his family owned the Chicago Tribune and
the Seattle times and a whole bunch of
other newspapers. And there
was a famous, you know,
fashion models and the family fleur
coals and stuff like that. So anyway,
so with Coles money, Fisher started
the econometric society, uh,
which is the most famous mathematical
society and economics, Econometrica,
which is the most famous journal in
economics. And the Coles Foundation,
which they moved,
which they started off in Colorado
Springs because cold Fisher set all the,
the weather's so good there, everyone
want to go there and it's good for them.
So nobody would go there.
So they had to move it to Chicago where
the Tribune was and it was in Chicago
from 1930 to 1955.
And then in 1955,
it moved to Yale.
And since then the Coles Foundation has
been a at Yale and you'll hear a lot
more about it later. But anyway,
so Kohl's with that background,
he set out to figure out how
to turn economics. In fact,
he invented economics, this model
of equilibrium to study finance.
But so far we don't have any finance in
the model. So how can you put it in? Well,
what is missing?
What do I need to put in the model in
order to have to turn it into finance?
What would you say is missing?
How would you turn this into finance?
What are the key thing? Yes. Okay.
So the first thing, oh, of course,
you may have read ahead in the notes,
but that's a brilliant insight.
If it's yours, um, you need,
you need time in the model.
So far we just had,
you know, apples and oranges
or something being traded.
So the first thing is Fisher said
you need to put time in the model.
What else is critically
missing in this model?
One other thing. The
major other thing. Yeah,
what?
Okay. Well that's good. There's
risk that's missing entirely.
So Fisher actually couldn't figure
out how to put that in the model,
but we're gonna, we're gonna get to
that. So what else did Fisher, what?
That was great. That's very
good. What else is missing?
Yup.
Okay. Wow. Okay. So time fishing,
you'll see had something to say about
time and impatience that people always
care more about the
present and the future.
But what other fundamental thing
about what is the finance all about?
When you think about finance,
what do you think about? Yes.
Great.
Okay. So you think about credit as
she said, credit interest rates.
Okay, and what else? Sure. Return. Okay,
that's quite related to that.
So all this has to go on the model,
but what fundamental object, when you
think the first thing you think about,
what do you think of? Yes. Money. Okay.
So that's not what I had in mind,
but I'm glad that you think about
that's what most of these, right?
That is what most people think
about. So money. So in this course,
we're not going to
provide a theory of money.
So Fisher did provide his theory of
money and that's what he was talking to
Roosevelt about all the time.
But we're not gonna. So he,
we're going to talk about inflation
and stuff like that, but not a theory.
We're not going to explain
where the inflation comes from.
So inflation is going
to be very important,
but we're not going to talk about a
theory of money. So what else is missing?
Something really basic though.
Yes.
Okay. So there are no banks and
things like that. Institutions.
Okay.
Okay. And still something come
on. What, what, what's the
what?
Loaning funds? Well, somebody said credit.
That's sort of loaning funds and
interest rates and collateral.
That's something that's good then
I'm going to add that. Thank you.
What a brilliant idea. And
what, what, what, what uh,
what basic thing come on. Yes. No. Well,
okay. That's in the model where as well,
it's already there.
So you know when you take your endowment
and you multiply it by the prices in
your budget set, that's your wealth.
So wealth is already, we've got,
well gabble capital. Okay,
so capital and let's say,
and what is capital? What do
you mean by capital? It's money.
I already told you that's not quite going
to be there. So contract will you? Okay,
so con, so we're getting
their contract assets. Okay.
So assets, that's the main thing that's
on my write it over here. Assets.
Okay.
After all the stock market is about,
I mean finances a lot about
the stock market, bond markets,
mortgage markets, those are all
assets that you buy that pay money,
pay dividends later.
So assets are things that pay
dividends at a later time.
That's the critical thing that's missing.
And when we talk about finance,
we want to know what should the
value of the stock market be,
how much should a mortgage be worth?
And it will turn and, and um, okay,
so those are the things we have to add.
Now how are we going to add them?
It sounds like you might have to just
totally Redo the theory and start from
scratch and do something
totally different.
How horrible that would be would
mean I also wasted three lectures.
So Fisher said you don't really
have to change very much at all.
So he said, number one time, how
do you put time in the model?
Simply think of,
think of why as the same
good
as x,
but one period later.
Okay,
so fish are sad. You know, time isn't
such a big deal. Already got two goods.
You know, these old, these, these crazy
marginalist before me, they had good acts,
which was interesting and this very
boring good why? And so you know, things,
it's not so clear how you can have
a time and everything in the model.
But I've already got two interesting
goods. X and Y, they're both, you know,
entering on, on the scene with the
same symmetric properties. I mean,
no, neither one of them seems
more interesting or more
important than the other
ones. So in fact maybe they're the same.
Good. It's just x and y is the same. Good.
It's one, one comes one period later.
Now next class we're going to talk about,
you're not going to value
them the same amount,
the utility for x and
why won't be the same.
So here a obviously things more of x
than he does of why. And by the way, B,
she also thinks more of x then she
does about why. So why is that? Well,
if y is the same as x,
but a year later people are impatient.
So the reason why a might like x better
than Y and B also is not because they're
different goods,
but because they're impatient.
So we're going to come to that later.
So we can have the idea that they're two
different time periods and the economy
simply by a change of
notation and not, uh, not, uh,
not introducing anything new at all.
Well,
what about assets?
How can you put sob coming?
They're going to come back to that
in the next class. What about assets?
How can you introduce assets
into the economy? Well,
Fisher says what is the
essence of an asset?
The essence of an acid is
that it's something you hold
today because later it's
going to deliver you money
or goods or something.
And we're not going to talk about money.
So we're imagining these
are all wheel acids. Um,
so they're going to deliver
goods in the future. So asset,
the definition of an asset is an asset.
Okay?
When we have to make it mathematical.
So the whole Fisher started the
society to make economics mathematical.
So an acid is literally something
that delivers goods in the future.
So an acid
defined
by its payoffs.
Okay.
The X and d y.
So we could call that acid alpha
[inaudible] acid alpha is defined by its
payoffs,
the acts and
Dyi. So it's going to pay a certain
amount of acts in a certain amount of why.
That's all there is.
Now we're going to ask,
do people actually know what the payoff
of why he's going to be if wise in the
future.
That means it hasn't happened yet.
Do we really know what was is going
to be and so Fisher, so we have to,
and so you know, maybe we know less about
one asset, more about another asset.
So maybe one assets riskier than
another acid. So someone said risk.
Obviously that's going be a
very fundamental question,
but before we come to risk,
if we don't have any risk yet,
cause Fisher didn't know how to put it
in and we're going to start with his
model where there's no risk.
Okay.
Then if there's just today and tomorrow
and everybody's rational, everybody,
since there's no one certain,
everybody wants to be able to anticipate
exactly what the dividends going to be.
So the acid is no different from
what its dividend is going to be.
Maybe it's paying something today and
also it's going to pay something tomorrow.
So assets are defined by their dividends.
Nothing more than that.
So if a model now becomes a model where
we have the aide Wri and then we have a
Wii,
and then we have the goods is
before the endowments of the goods.
But we've added a new thing,
which is we've added the acids,
d alpha acts and d l for y.
Okay?
So the ALFALFA's overall the assets,
and we have to add everybody's
ownership of the assets to begin with.
So we have to have theta,
I'm going to call it fate of Bar Alpha.
Okay.
Ate a bar.
I alpha.
So how much of acid Alpha does I own?
So that's the economy that
we're going to start with. Okay?
So we've made the model much more,
we made the model a bit more complicated.
We started what we were,
we did before with utilities
and endowments of chords.
Now we're adding acids,
which pay off more goods and where,
and of course people begin owning trees.
And stuff like that.
So a tree is an acid, it's going
to pay Apple's later on and people,
various different people
own various different trees.
So we've got to the old economy,
we add something new and now fishers,
ingenious insight was that
if you think about this,
which we will for a little while,
you'll be able to discover that you can
simplify this economy back down to the
economy we began with.
So you can start talking about acids and
interest and all kinds of other things
using the same analysis before.
So with my last thought here,
what would you, what has interest
have to do with px over p? Why?
Suppose they're both. What does px over
p why? Suppose they're both apples.
So acts as an apple today.
Why is an apple next year?
What does px over p?
Why it says how much an apple is worth
today relative to how much an apple was
worth tomorrow. So, so,
so this is going to turn out to be
one plus the real interest rate.
Fisher would call it.
Yeah.
Because if Px is more than p
y, let's say px is a, you know,
20% more than p. Why what it means
is by giving up one apple today,
you can get 1.2 apples tomorrow.
That's just what happens when
you put money in the bank.
You give up something today, you get
exactly the same thing back next period.
But more of it.
So you see,
just by having time and the
price is like we had before,
you're going to see very how interest,
acids,
everything is going to start
coming into play very quickly.
So I didn't put the problem set on the
web yet cause I wasn't sure how far we'll
get,
but I'll put it on in a couple hours
and we'll start again on Thursday.